[Music]
the passing of time has always been a
bit of an issue for me and when i was 12
i remember going to the baseball diamond
with christian and we threw the ball
around it was on the eve of your 13th
birthday yeah and i got really emotional
i remember walking to the baseball field
with you and
you were so melancholy you were this 12
year old kid pre-puberty yeah and you
were like this is the last night of my
childhood this is it
and to celebrate i just want to do
something that kids do and they throw
the ball around that's what you wanted
to do your your wish on the last night
of your childhood
was to play catch with me but i remember
thinking it's the last time i'll be able
to do that right i'll now i'll be an
adult i'll be 13 i'll be a man and the
irony is we are middle-aged men now when
we play catch with each other all the
time throw the ball around the time
so i guess it wasn't the last night of
your childhood after all
just the beginning
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your grown-up middle-aged man
middle-aged kid man boy justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always as he was
and the dawn of my 13th year 14th year
13th birthday yeah 14th year yeah
christian long number hi
we still play baseball but i
i still have a complex too about
it's taken it on a different form but
but about time moving on and
getting older i mean as people who
listen to the show probably you know
they're acutely aware
i read an article nah
recently about
adults playing the concert of play yeah
and how important it is for adults to
continue to play and how
that's an element of an adult's life
that's very often overlooked
um and all the things it does for you i
mean emotionally and mentally oh i bet
it's so good so just
playing catch with your friend
uh is as an adult is a very healthy
thing to do it's still fun
it's still fun i don't do it enough i
don't do team sports enough but the last
time i was just talking about this
because i sprained my ankle last year
first one i was doing on stage and then
i
i made it really bad later that day when
i tried to play basketball with a bunch
of like kids half my age they were like
19 year olds and it was the goofiest
move i tried to avoid a ball and i like
hopped on my foot and i just came down
on it so weird and i was too embarrassed
to be like people were like hey man like
subtext was hailed man who probably
shouldn't be playing was you okay and i
was like yeah yeah yeah and it hurts so
bad and i continued to
play on it for which probably
exacerbated it and i like hobbled out of
there and uh i was injured for a couple
weeks i was while i was doing this play
so i yeah the body just starts breaking
down but up until that point it had been
so fun
playing with these kids it's i remember
when
you know we've talked about this so many
times in the show about how quickly your
body recovers uh when you're younger
from anything and i i remember when i
was uh i woke up one morning when i was
turned 30 and i
and i uh my knee hurt and i thought oh
for sure i heard it last night i just
don't remember maybe i had one too many
beers and i don't remember twisting it
or something and uh come to find out it
was just arthritis i got arthritis in my
right knee really yeah and you're 30.
yeah and it stuck around for like two
years and now it's fine yeah you didn't
oh yeah i used to get it like drained
yeah it looks gross
uh it's true but it's gross who are our
sponsors today
um the passage of time is something that
we are we struggle with we struggle with
but we're interested in and we like it's
one of the reasons we like doing the
show we like to
know how people make the most out of
this precious life that we've all been
given and
our guest today is
very special to us and she i think it's
very very fair to say has
more than made the most of the
opportunities she's been given in this
life
are our guest today is our grandmother
our josephine josephine or jody or jody
lesniak um and she is 102 years old
she's
almost 103.
and she'll be 103 in about a month
and she is a really
good example in my opinion of someone
who
really lives life in in a healthy
positive way well she's always been very
curious she's very curious and sometimes
it can potentially be annoying what are
you doing you know wants to know
everything
every tabs keeping tabs uh but i i think
now looking back and people are always
asking her like what's your secret and
how do you do it and i i think it has a
lot to do with that it's just
being invested in life what's amazing
about her is that she's just still she's
so sharp yeah you're about to hear yeah
uh much she's very [ __ ] you'll agree
listeners that she is still quite with
it especially for her age we we actually
have two
102 year old grandmothers yes if you can
believe it um our father's mother is
also 102 years old and also quite sharp
also quite sharp it's
it's funny how uh frequently i brag
about having two hundred and two i do
grandma
people like i accomplished something i
know and people always it's almost like
complimenting somebody on on their dog
being cute i know i have nothing to do
with that but it's i guess it's a little
bit more it's a little more personal
yeah
but we do share
genetic yeah and people that's always
people's response often is you must have
gucci yeah and my self-deprecating
response is always oh no the men in our
family die off yeah
you both have to have the same
self-deprecating response to a
compliment about your genes
but or i'll go to my face like yeah good
genes maybe longevity-wise but not
necessarily face right
but speaking of faces if you do want to
put a visual to this uh podcast because
she's not famous she's not yet famous
she's our first guest who's not faced
yeah yeah but she's famous to us and
she's famous to some people in lake
worth florida
on instagram i recently posted a and
today i'll post pictures of this of her
i would say everyone's grandmother is
the best everyone says they're about
their grandmother but i i think she's
the best i think she's amazing i think
she was always uh
so present in our lives they they lived
in florida for my entire life she and
her um now deceased husband my
grandfather uh but she was always so
present despite living so far away they
both were my memories of grandpa are
clear but i remember he was very playful
he was a very playful guy i remember
playing
burrs with him he would throw getting
into like little bird fights and um
he was silly and
a little intimidating he had a very
unique
smell like aftershave smell um
and that style remember that style from
like the 40s where they'd slick back
their hair he still had those
so i still have i have clear memories of
him but grandma who you'll hear was
always helping she was always she always
wanted to make herself useful she's got
a tremendous guilt complex and you'll
hear probably
where it comes from uh she had to grow
up very quickly and take care of her
father and
get into that but um
she was always mending something and
sewing and cooking an amazing cook like
made her own gnocchi and
her sister or aunt rosie made the best
pasta and you hear this too like oh my
grandmother but god but they were in
some ways they were like the
stereotypical
italian yes
overly doting our aunt rosie was always
like dude your skin and bones look have
some of my lasagna she'd take out a big
tray of like like when did you make this
look i didn't see you doing anything and
and the husbands were like very strong
and supportive and her husband was but
and we'd watch football together and the
smell of pasta was in the air it was
really great memories she watches
jeopardy and wheel of fortune every
night and she is remarkably good at both
of those shows and sharp she's so sharp
still it's it's incred i i
just recently i was watching wheel of
fortune with her and there was like
three letters revealed and this whole
puzzle and she got it it blew my mind
she's crazy at wheel of fortune you know
to the point where sometimes uh and
there are a lot of old people near where
she lives so when i take her out when we
go to dinner and stuff um
often old people will come up and
they'll
they'll come up to me and you know and
then i want to brag about my grandmother
so i'll say
you know she's she's the one you should
be interested in she's a 102 and
people like 20 years younger than her
and they're in their like 70s 80s will
be like we'll talk to her like she's a
little kid you know kink wow
you must be doing something right like
really like patronizing
and uh
and
grandma will like turn to me and like
roll her eyes and say like the wittiest
funniest thing she'll be like
uh yeah i can hear you like why are you
talking to me like i'm a three-year-old
you know she's just like really
sarcastic and the irony is like she's
probably a lot more with it than these
people who are like
paying her this kind of right compliment
i'm not sure if she's gonna like me
saying this but one more thing i want to
say about her before we get into this
she uh for the last few years i would
say since her late 90s
she's been trying to lose a few pounds
and she's not overweight by any means
she's like little you know she's short
check her out on instagram yeah she's
like she we always say she looks a
little like nicki minaj
like an older nicki minaj slightly yeah
calm down
the menagerie do they call nicki minaj
menagerie at the menagerie they should
they should for the last few years she's
been trying to lose a couple pounds
because
do you know this no because she of her
idol doesn't want her uh coughing her to
be too happy yeah she doesn't want the
pallbearers to have to lift
more weight than they need to
when she's in her coffin that kind of
says that kind of that kind of sums her
up yeah she's the best and you're about
to
hear why we think she's the best i think
uh coming up now
justin's
chat with our grandma jody
[Music]
that's just you and me yep
so we're just talking we're not even
recording
when do we record well when it starts
cracking you know when it starts getting
good
when do you ask me my name what is your
name
jody
you want me to say josephine yeah your
whole name
josephine
lesner
but you and you have a middle name
i think when i was very little someone
asked me that and i said nell
why i don't know any ll because you love
the movie with jodie foster josephine
nell
and you just made it up
well somebody asked me what is your
middle name and you felt like i didn't
have one oh so i said no because you
like the name oh
all right do you feel silly
i do yeah
we're not used to talking to each other
on microphones not really
uh have you ever done anything like this
no okay okay
um first of all how old are you
102
yes so you'll be 103
on december 31st on january 1st
yeah but for a long time you thought
your birthday was
you don't want to say that
okay the law is not going to come after
you
you're hundred she's 103. but because
technically there was a
misrepresentation
when you were born your your dad
made your age a day older than you were
right you said i was born before
midnight
and i mean after afternoon and i was
born a few minutes before midnight which
is really i feel sorry for my poor dad
he didn't get his boy yeah
he was supposed to be joseph oh really
yes
why why did they think it was gonna be
they had a boy
and the boy got that ear infection which
today they fix
but when he was six months old he died
oh my god and my father was
livid
and then they had rosie it was six
months when he died
and then they had rosie then she was
pregnant with me
and
daddy thought it was gonna be a boy so
joseph is gonna be born
and so um
it turned out to be josephine oh no
did he ever did he dress you in like boy
clothes and stuff no because then they
had a couple more miscarriages
and then they had gloria so then they
gave up so we never had
developed cancer and the ear infection
that's something that they can cure
today
today it's nothing isn't that crazy that
you
lived through so many illnesses that are
now obsolete
absolutely didn't your other relatives
have scarlet although spanish flu
my uncle joe lived with us
he and i were the only two in the family
that didn't get the flu it was my mother
my father rosie
and we had always a cousin or two
staying there
because they would come from italy
and you always had to take care of them
till they take care of themselves yeah
so we always
had a couple of cousins living with us
wait i want to get back to the spanish
flu
but your whole family's from italy yeah
so when did they come over your your dad
came over first my dad came with a bunch
of his fellows a fellow men
and they wanted to come and see those
roads paved in gold we've got to go see
that uh are we recording no we're just
talking
i gotta say this again no no no no
no we're recording we're recording
yeah we're recording
wait so what was his name
so where was that
he came with his fellow his fellow man
yes they wanted to go see the roads that
are paved with gold and the money's
flying all around that's what they all
thought so he says well my father was
very good with the um
blacksmith business oh yeah and he was
had a great teacher he worked for you
know they work under them
and an apprentice you just made quite a
bit of money for a little country kid
yeah so he had the money he said sure
i'd take a vacation
early 1900s yeah he's a young guy so
he's very young very handsome with this
red curly hair red curly hair he had
sort of dark red but he had red
auburn hair i didn't know that yeah
that isn't where will's hair comes from
that comes from his mother that's irish
red oh okay my cousin will who's
hopefully listening so um
anyhow
they got on the spoons yeah and it took
over a month oh my god to get to new
york city it's crazy and my father had a
lot of throwing he was sick he was
throwing up
the ocean yeah you know you get sick
and uh because those boats weren't made
like they're made today yeah the rocking
bags the first thing he did was sit down
and write to his mother and father i'm
never coming back again oh my god i'm
never coming back all his friends went
back at me no
because he didn't want to deal with he
didn't want to deal with that stupid
quote again
and of course with the art in his hands
of what he could do he got a job right
away because there weren't a lot of
people who had his skills he worked on
the uh i don't know how he got to
rochester from new york
i guess they knew somebody so he landed
at ellis island oh yeah
i mean you know it wasn't easy those
days if you weren't healthy you got back
on the next boat and you were sent back
wow if you didn't have anybody say
if you didn't have any money and there
was nobody to talk for you you get sent
back immigration was always tough my
mother came
to
to stay with her brother
because her mother had died and she
they all had six seven eight kids
family so but your mom hadn't met your
dad yet oh no no no
so she came to live in rochester from
sicily from abruzzazi
you've got the most beautiful beach you
ever wanted to see i want to see how he
how did she meet
aunt lou
you remember me talking about my
girlfriend lou
she's not your girlfriend you're just
platonic friend
oh i'm not talking today yeah
not your lover
no no no no
forgiving no lou i'm just trying to
clarify for the listeners that you guys
were just friends my girlfriend at the
time i don't care what anybody says yeah
no no one else is saying other things
there's no rumor about it
her mother
was married to a guy that he had a job
and he'd bring home half his bait to his
wife
and the other half he used to like to go
and gamble oh and she had so many kids
and so many bills
so she rented out a couple rooms she had
a big house
and my mother rented a room from her i'm
not sure how my mother met my father and
she told
lou's mother
oh i met a nice man
so she's bring him in i want to meet him
so she shook hands with him
and so she said to my mother he's got
nice rough hands he's a worker you marry
him whoa and she did
feel my hands how soft they are
like a baby's bottom
it's callous from holding a phone too
much
and my
mother's family
was in the baking business yes they had
the only bakery in their little town
in in
when they came here
that was their trade her brothers were
working for the bakery oh
but she was working
on canal street for boots and done i
think and right next door is where they
made the beautiful cars the name escapes
me well it's okay it was awesome
car made by rose rolls-royce
no
it might come to me
italian father did all the blacksmithing
part of it oh for that car and each car
had its own plan each car was wow lots
of money oh my god they're made for rich
people somehow they met
could have been on the street because
they worked next door i don't know isn't
that crazy sometimes i think like if
they hadn't if she hadn't said something
like marry that man or they hadn't
somehow met and happened to we wouldn't
be talking right now no oh no
two other people yeah we would who knows
who we'd be maybe better people you're
born in the year
1917
1916. elliot was born in 2000 1917.
2017. he was born
in october yeah that would be 10. oh 10
19 19 17. that's true i hunt so this is
my gran my my uh nephew
your great-grandson
see how good i am at this very good um
so so he's a hundred years isn't that
amazing what was it what is it like to
see life right now like new life
unbelievable
and it just makes me stop and think
every one of us
came out this little thing yeah and look
at the size of some of us well not you
you're still little
i've lost about two inches two inches of
height yes oh i'm the shortest one every
place now and you have to sit on pillows
i don't know how to say this other than
like how do you feel about still being
alive what does that feel like knowing
that you're kind of on borrowed time but
you've outlived everyone since i thought
i was going to die at 42
that's when your mom died my god she was
42. i mean i shouldn't have told wendy
any of this because she's been a wreck
about it yeah it's made her very
neurotic
but you know
well my mother died at 42 now i'm 42
because i'm gonna die pretty soon
that's how you thought it was brainless
and so but no it makes sense that's what
you knew growing up oh you also knew a
lot of you were surrounded by death and
sickness and we were talking about the
spanish flu when that hit in the
nineteen late nine almost nine like
1920s
1919 spanish flu was devastating and
like you said a lot of years can you
figure out why my uncle and i didn't get
it in the family and everybody else got
it well like many other things you've
been lucky
that's one of th that's a that's a very
major instance where you've been lucky
but
uncle joe died at 71.
uncle joe who didn't get it he didn't
get it but he died when he was 71. how
did he die
he had multiple he had the cancer of the
blood
but at the time
do you so you avoid the spanish flu
most almost all of your relatives get it
are you then you're then put in charge
of taking care of people do you have to
take and then when your mom died of
course you you sort of have to assume
the role
mom died we were i was a nine when i
started she at 11 when she died
i have to give her shots of no of um
morphine morphine yeah and we got so
that we couldn't find any flesh any
place
because she was in bed for about
nine or ten months oh my god almost a
year and just agony just agony so it was
too much we'd have to give her a shot
and they taught me how to do it i was 9
or 10 years old
and rosie did it
very devastating one day
in the middle of the sickness
she wanted to come downstairs
so they got her dressed
and they helped her come down the stairs
and she sat in a big chair in the dining
room and we were all oh we were so happy
she's going to she's coming back she's
going to be better it was just the one
day
she never did it again oh my god so is
that and the little tiny austin the
drugstore car
would back up into our driveway
several times a week bringing drugs and
whatever they needed we were a good
customer
and in the beginning we had a private
nurse for her
but after six months
even the doctor said to my father all
you need is a housekeeper you don't need
a nurse here
knowing that she was gonna die my father
would pay anything do anything to get to
keep her
were you angry when that happened i mean
were you angry at god were you angry at
the world i was too young to know what
to do except we were very sad we cried a
lot because we didn't want to see her
suffer yeah
so 42 and that's got to shape you uh
immeasurably
she was such a smart lady
she was she had to be smart she had a
good growing up her
her
mother and father's bakery was on one
side of the street
and across the street was a little
private driveway that went up to a
beautiful home
the rich people of the city who were
little town
had one daughter
and they didn't want to raise her alone
so they asked my mother's mother and
father
could we borrow your daughter what so
they took over
francesca batza
and they brought her over gave her the
same upbringing that their rich little
girl had you're kidding my mother was
raised
very oh she was so that she would that
picture of her and i'll show you when we
get back yeah with her holding me as a
baby
she was very up to stuff and was always
into the latest things she's really
defined seam oh my god she'd crochet and
do anything cook bake do and that was
all from learning it from the rich
people yeah
wow so she was so
baker's daughter she was
very well brought up oh
but your
mother ever tell you this no i didn't
know this but how did her parents your
grandparents then
did they feel strange her mother had
died oh
so
i think when her father died then the
boys took over the bakery
the girls helped so she was almost like
rented out by this family of an only
child you know everybody was happy
because everybody made well
now so your mother grows up with outside
of her meet her parents means she grows
up with this rich family
and then when she comes over here and
she meets your mom your father
they move to rochester they don't have a
lot of money
well
so father always made good money but not
like rich person like rich but not the
way your mom grew up and she was working
for the first few months and
then she got pregnant that was it
she was definitely a house mother so
when you were a kid growing up in that
home
what did a home look like what is that
what are the most striking
was absolutely
spotless she was the neatest person we
used to have a guy who i forgot what he
was whether he was partly related but he
used to come off and to check up on
francis's kids after she died
and um friends used to tell my father
she is she was the cleanest lady that i
had ever met he said i would eat off of
her floors oh my god was she do you
remember her always cleaning
she would get up early in the morning
and she would do all her dusting and
cleaning and everything and she would
start cooking
those days you started in the morning to
get ready for supper oh my god like what
kind of stuff would she cook because
they didn't have refrigerators right
yeah we had refrigerators oh you did in
fact when we moved to arnott boulevard
we had the outside door where the iceman
could put the ice right in from the
outside he didn't have to come in the
house oh it was and that was considered
a little better that was kind of fancy
yeah oh so he would how often would the
iceman come
every day i think oh this is good that'd
make a good play but you know the iceman
cometh
pretty good
do you ever think about that like um
when you open a fridge or when you're
around modern technology and how how
much easier it's made life do you ever
think god we used to have to
we're so different i always say boy
things really have changed well they
when your lifetime they've it's been
really changed drastic what are well the
first time we got a telephone wow
how old we got a telephone we were on a
four-party line what does that mean you
have to share it with four other yeah i
mean maybe the guy next door the guy in
back of you and so they're all on that
same line so you go pick up the phone
maker oops i'm using oh pardon me oh my
god
did you ever hear did you ever listen in
on you know people's conversations
because they could tell you oh oh they
could tell and then there were the two
party lines that's really and then the
single party line oh that's for like
president take long for us to get the
single party oh right in this so this is
like late 1920s
i think my mother was
yeah your mom was alive so late 1920s
because
so and then the depression happens the
stock market crashes
my father was still working
and everybody else had been laid off
and how did that he didn't know
if he was really going to get laid off
or not
but he was working in at mdt in east
rochester what's mdt
merchant's dispatch
transportation what was he doing there
he was working for the new york central
making the trains doing stuff on the
trains
and his bosses loved his work and would
say
you know lawrence if you would just
teach somebody what you're doing
because they everybody always said that
to him because he was so good he could
do stuff and he knew just how to do you
know yeah if you could just so he had
asked me once if i'd write it down if he
would tell me what he was doing oh i
said sure
he needed an apprentice he always had an
apprentice the apprentice
cried
more at my father's wake than anybody
else wow
he just oh i'm gonna miss him so much oh
he was crying crying did you keep in
touch with that
person no he's probably dead now too
yeah well yeah i mean safe to say
um and and so you weren't noticeably
affected by the stock market crash of
2012. then he did get laid off but he
had been saving his money almost the
first thing he did when he got paid was
save money
and then he'd put the rest in a drawer
for my mother to use and she'd say oh
it's not my money
of course it's your money he was um very
generous with her and so was he
devastated after she died was he able to
move on well when he first learned that
she's definitely going to die there's
nothing we can do for her
he told everybody he went down cellar
and he hit his head against the concrete
what am i going to do i've got three
girls how am i going to raise them he
was he went crazy yeah i bet
did you
sense a change in him
did you well you know we always thought
he was mean you can't do this you can't
do that i mean
yeah yeah you're going to get hurt you
can't do this what do you think i know i
never could ride a bike i never could
skate i never could do anything
because you could break a leg you can't
slide on the sled and the snow you want
to break your leg like that kid did
across the street he was overprotective
yeah
do you think any of that uh effective
effectively yeah yeah and how you raised
so then you raised my mind that's a good
thing that your grandfather married me
yeah because he was more adventurous he
was awful i'll let him do it he if you
were afraid that my mom would get hurt
don't let her skate or don't let her do
this he would say jody
stop it
yeah he called you jody let her do yeah
yeah oh that's good jake sometimes i'd
say where does that come from jake jake
would he call you jake sometimes did he
ever say why
no
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when you were a kid was there something
that you wanted to be that you just felt
like oh this is just a dream and you
never pursued it you know there must be
something wrong with me because as a kid
i was always happy with who i was and
what i had and what
i never was
wishing for anything no there's nothing
wrong that's actually really good no i i
never but like you told me once that you
would go to the movies a lot
oh yeah when after the during the
depression well when mama first died and
we used to go every saturday with rose
and another i think doors
a couple kids yeah and for 10 cents you
could go to the movies honey wow and we
would bring little stuff to eat and we'd
sit there and watch them oh we had a
lady playing the piano oh yeah because
it was uh still silent there were still
silent movies there was enough of that
yeah
do you remember
having favorite actors favorite uh
matinee rogers and claraboo
clear about
charlie chaplin did you like
yeah yeah all the ones that we're
playing were our favorites laurel and
hardy
yeah so you would go to the movies all
the time and then there was always the
newsreels
and so that's how you would get the news
and you would listen to the radio too
i remember listening to the first
televised
oscar awards
my father was upstairs sleeping but i
guess he could hear something and so he
would open the door and you know
go to bed
all right it's time to go to bed
is this am i making this up did how
green was my valley when oh that was so
good yeah that's a long time ago but you
but did you ever think oh i want to do
because you then had a daughter my mom
who became an actress whose dream it was
to be an actress
but did you ever think oh i could
that would be fun to do well i always
thought it would be wonderful to do that
but since my girlfriend lou
wanted to be an actress oh she did
and we let her borrow my graduation
dress
to go to something at the rko pills
uh-huh she thought she was gonna win and
go to hollywood and be a star it was
like a talent competition
what was it oh god i remember that we
had to take the trolley downtown
she was wearing like a fancy looking
dress my dress was really quite lovely i
designed it and the lady next door made
it for me because she
doesn't have a mother she's gonna to
graduate
they felt bad for you
no but but you learned from your mom how
to sew and cook and all that well she
taught us as much as you could teach a
nine-year-old yeah
but you know all that i mean you learn
all that stuff from you and then i tried
to do better afterwards because i knew
that she would want me to
and the fact that you're 102 103 almost
that must be
more than twice that lived more than
yeah
yeah so at what point did you think
this is just comical that i'm still here
yeah i think quite a while ago i decided
that i better stop thinking about i'm
gonna die tomorrow or the next day
because you don't know when you're gonna
die right after i'd see you you would
always say
i would say well i'll see you soon and
you would say i don't know
i know and now you don't say that
anymore every time we used to come down
and see wendy when she was married and
moved to connecticut my husband wendy's
so often he would say you want to go and
see wendy this weekend and uh okay let's
go and then he would take care of
whatever kids she had and i would help
her and she could go to new york and
work uh yeah so my mom was an actress at
the time how did you meet grandpa
sampson united
what's samson united i've worked in the
office and so did he
um
they made rubber bladed fans did you
ever know oh i didn't know that are you
serious yeah they made toasters toasters
iron flat irons all kinds of little
stuff
and um
he was in the um
then there was vitorama that's part of
the war effort oh wait it's world war ii
oh world war ii came
and um i remember jimmy cummings
party
because he worked in the production
office and he was the first one to get
drafted wow and we had a party on
saturday night and
so i got
to meet my husband a little bit better
and then there was another party for
somebody else oh you had to you got to
you mean you got to meet him like no i
mean i got to talk to him know him more
and because otherwise you know you each
one would mind their own business so
the first time you met him it was just
brief it was just like you didn't talk
much well you know he was a kid in
production office and
and i was in the uh purchasing office
and so grandpa was uh working nearby
nearby did he ask you out
well of course he asked me out but i
can't remember when it was his number
was called he had to go grandpa so yes
and he went to buffalo he was going to
be
drafted to the medical he was drafted he
was the medical thing and everybody we
had a party for him and i still wasn't
oh you weren't
oh wow were you nervous i was at his
party and the next thing you know he's
back at work
he had a hole in his ear and it was
going to his brain right
and anyhow that's when we got closer and
that's when we started going out right
my father wasn't too happy that he was
not italian oh
right
and his mother wasn't too happy that i
was not polish
oh boy see those things happened honey
yeah they're still happening
so willie's mother who was polish was
upset that you were italian yeah and
there's a turning point in your
relationship with your mother-in-law
where she went from despising you and
not wanting him to be with you
to loving you
well
the reason is i had a car
and everybody else was working yeah
during the war this is a stay-at-home
mother
and so i would take her
different places your mother-in-law my
mother despite the fact that she
could we call it bobcat did not like you
she was a very stern woman well she
never did anything to to just you know
but no
my husband knew you know
she wasn't doing it yeah stella was the
first one she she married a german slave
to marriage
syllabus
yeah no i know but stella was grandpa's
uh sister older sister
and uh so she married a german during
world war ii you lose
and florian was so bobcat must have been
not the best
oh what does that mean not the best
german
he wasn't very caring or thoughtful or
no not the best person
no the first thing he did when he moved
to florida and his boys were pretty big
take them to these adult places what
when stella tell us that i says what
father would bring their sons to these
places you mean like the one we passed
on the road gentlemen's clubs but
they're not necessarily gentlemen who go
there i don't know what goes on in there
yeah you've never been in one you've
never been in one
so he took his kids there
he introduced his boys he told him how
to go and have a good time oh my gosh
weird so bobcat so babka um
he propositioned your mother once
what
he was here i wanted to take her out
and steli said don't you dare go up with
it
you know she knew what he was like but
she couldn't so stella was that florian
was his her
husband wait so that makes florian my
mom's uncle
right what
and that is not a favorite one i hope
not no he was
oh my too good so bob send her rights
yes yeah she had a good
it was
yeah bobcat made a good call on that one
but it wasn't just because he was german
it was because he was like a pervious
idiot yeah
but she at first was kind of cold to you
and not warm she just wasn't warm so
then you were the one with the car you
were a stay at home and i got her
35 a month
in social security which she had never
gotten before
how did you get her that took her to the
office
my husband saw something in the paper
and he said i'd take her but
i got to work so then you drove babka i
drove her up there i helped her sign the
papers and everything and the first
check she got she called me up
i got my money i it's my money so bobcat
didn't have money growing up
well no yeah so the fact that you helped
her get this social security yeah so it
was only a lousy 35 dollars sonny but
she was so grateful no but her money was
coming to her and nobody could touch it
but it's also the fact that you she had
like fourteen hundred dollars in the
bank when she died she thought she was a
rich lady oh my god she thought i was
the king's potatoes wow i'm never that
expression i guess that's one that they
don't use anymore
[Laughter]
what so
so you're working now and you have first
my mom in 1945
44. oh 44. i should have known that she
was just 75. and how did that change
your life how did that oh it was
great yeah
did you know did you want to be long
baby
yeah
and then you didn't have john until
10. he didn't come along nine whole
years nine years was that the plan or or
no that just
happened so you didn't want it
well well you didn't necessarily want to
have more children then oh yeah yeah oh
yeah
uh and and then then we thought two was
enough after that oh okay
well
willie was getting older yeah well and
what were the some of the big
differences that's me
just would just just willy you were you
were staying the same age
i was 35 or six when he was born and
that's at the time is pretty old to be
having a kid today they started 40. yeah
and you were probably thinking at the
time oh i only have a few years to live
i have to 42.
you
you've outlived willie by 32 years now
it's been 32 years 32 years does it seem
like that long or does it well all i
know is that
we moved to florida you moved and he
lived
seven years enjoying florida like nobody
i know you moved to florida in 1980
right 1979.
sorry
and he played golf he went swimming he
went fishing he did everything he loved
it
and he joined everything at the place he
was
on the board and he was
right and everything
and i just tagged along
but i made friends too
but anyhow then he died
yeah
and i thought well definitely now i'm
gonna
what am i still doing it oh you thought
that and then here it is 32 years and
i'm still here honey well how do you
feel about that
i don't know what god wants me to do
yeah must be something i haven't done
maybe this
well you know the na do you know the
name of the show the name of the show is
called life is short oh i didn't know
that yeah
it was a good place for me
yeah mine isn't too short
how does it feel and i ask you this a
lot when people come up to you and and
they hear that you're 102
what are people how do people what is
your secret yeah and i say i don't think
i have a secret
you just
try to do what's right
well do what you've been told well yeah
but like well there are a couple things
i think that contribute to your
longevity
you're very curious
you want to know inquisitiveness doesn't
stop yes
didn't you want to go to united states i
wanted to be a teacher when i was in
high school but i was in high school
when uh the depression came when my
father finally got laid off and then i
realized how can i go to college daddy
won't have any money oh
[Music]
so do you regret that not going
yeah but then somebody i know was in the
same boat that i was in and she was a
teacher and she said well you know they
have help for people like us as somebody
helped her do something and she get she
went through the school but financially
and i said oh i didn't know that see
when you don't have a mother yeah i mean
my father did what he could but he
didn't know about that stuff because my
mother would have taken care of them
and so she wasn't there i went to work
for the man next door i worked in his
office he had precision
fabricators after high school yeah and i
worked there for a while and then i went
to sampson united where you met grandpa
right really and i stayed home grandpa
avoided going to the war because he
wasn't drafted because of his ear
condition and that was a condition that
almost then killed him well
the first couple weeks that we were home
after we were married
he got this awful cold and he couldn't
get rid of it and i went through the
phone book at the doctors you know
they're only about two pages of doctors
finally found this doctor lowly and the
girl said yeah bring him in today
so
while we were waiting in the waiting
room to get in to see the doctor
this other guy was sitting there and he
said boy this is the best doctor
and he was the one that did remember the
prince of wales that married that
divorcee wallace okay
and they sent him to where dr loewy was
in budapest or wherever he was
and he operated on him oh wow so he was
very good and so when we got there the
nerd the nurse said well you came to the
right doctor so we pa i picked well yeah
and so in those days it was like just a
few dollars
and you paid as you were walked out and
there's no bills no insurance nothing
the best doctor wow and so we stayed
with him one day um he was real nervous
about this ear
you're willing i don't know if that hole
has been
growing this past year
or for the last 40 years yeah so he said
the best thing to do is i've got to
operate on his ear and i've got to do it
as soon as possible
wow
so he cleaned it all out wow no up until
that time your grandfather had to wash
his ear out every day and then put this
cotton here gosh
and every day he'd take that cotton out
and he'd go over the stinks oh this
stuff was coming out oh my god but the
doctor had told his mother as long as
the stuff comes out
you're okay when it stops coming out
then you're in trouble oh
wow then that means it was going
somewhere yeah towards the brain
so anyhow he cleaned them out so there
was no more danger of that going to the
brain so dr loewy so you that saved his
life yeah wow and then when he wanted to
retire
he
he chose six names out of his
list of patients and he asked them to
come to the university of rochester once
a month whenever they had to come
because he wanted to take care he wanted
to take care of your grandparents oh i
wanted to
he he had us keep seeing this wow and so
we thought well we'll be with him a long
time yeah and um
then one day he was going home from work
and he had a heart attack and died in
his car oh my god poor thing but he he
so loved grandpa and that he wanted to
keep wow well so
was that finished no sorry
we're getting there uh which is where do
you have to be with you okay
well thanks life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
people are amazed when they hear you're
102. yeah
when i'm like with winnie or with
anybody when is your friend who's 80. we
meet somebody of their friends yeah and
then i hear them saying she's 102. yeah
oh my god
is it that much of a thing that you have
to tell everybody no
yeah i think it is you should be proud i
mean that's people want to have more
life remote for the most part if it's a
good life i mean you want to have more
life right if i'm well yeah i know i
know we so i want you to move to
connecticut and you're into it into a
house i just got but you're resistant
yeah i'm trying to pitch it maybe people
can write in and convince you to move
there but you've gotten so used to
florida because you've lived here since
1979 see this is my house see how when
you you won you always said
fairfield that's your house connecticut
yeah yeah
this feels like home and you don't want
to leave home
but isn't it hard for you now to get
another reason is like getting around is
difficult for you now because you don't
drive you know i'm not sure how much
longer i can do my shopping right i'm
not sure how much longer i can go to
church on sunday morning these are
important things
when he picks me up so i've gotten used
to it now then we always go to breakfast
someplace
you used to go to breakfast at johnny
g's
well we used to go to breakfast there
and then we usually go to gun club cafe
or dante's what about there's another
one i forget the name oh a lot of shout
outs you're giving a lot of shout outs
oh hello
but was that hard to give up your
driveway
i knew it was going to be bad because
when my sister had to give up driving
because she had lost
the side of one eye and she was losing
the other one and her kids wouldn't
didn't want her to drive anymore yeah
and so she said she had to give it up
but she kept saying to me don't you ever
give up driving don't give up driving
really because then like that's because
just think if you couldn't drive how
you'd feel can't do what you want so
then
you kind of have to remain home most of
the day right well i am home a whole lot
more than i used to be and does that
ever get sad or lonely or
no no no i don't get lonely really
do you i'm used to being alone now yeah
and then you watch wheel of fortune and
then jeopardy
yeah there's always a movie on that
hallmark channel oh yeah you like
hallmark movies well they're all alike
yeah
you're probably so sick of this but what
is the secret you haven't really said
didn't you have a dietary secret every
day you would eat a certain thing every
single day
and you know what it is yes
raisins and gin
that's just recent oh really it's in the
last maybe 10 years okay well those are
tough years to stay alive because when i
had arthritis i still have arthritis
anyhow this one fella that was working
monday mornings
at church with us
uh martin he said something about did
you ever try the raisins and gin
i said what
explain to me what he does i saw sounds
interesting
i like raisins i like gin
i'm listening so i tried it and you know
after a couple weeks i'd say marty i
don't think that thing is much good
he's like oh you gotta try it at least a
month or two it takes time maybe he was
trying to get you drunk he's trying to
get me used to getting yeah maybe he
maybe he knew you were single and he was
trying to slowly get you drunk
it was a long game
he was playing the long game he was
married is marty still alive no no no
everybody does
everybody
what is that like what is it like when
all these people that you know
have died
and now younger people than me are dying
well yeah and my goodness here i am when
i was young nobody lived past 65 or 70.
right
yeah that was rare especially during the
spanish flu oh they died like flies yeah
yeah why are you laughing
oh my poor uncle how did he take care of
everybody and me
isn't that amazing
you know uncle joe
was almost like a father to us yeah my
father was busy with work and all his
stuff that he did and uncle joe would
take us to buy
the school things
books and book bags and gloves and
scarves and boots and what is it like
for you to see people buying things
online now or the existence of these
computers and the delivery guys keep
coming every day yeah some people i know
never go to a store they do everything
online you know i i pick things up and i
check them out and i look them over and
this way you take whatever they give you
oh well you can send it back
yeah
you know it's not the same and and you
get a lot of calls now we were just
talking about this you get a lot of
calls from people trying to to take
money from you robot
robocalls
yeah i'll bet i have at least 10 a day
10 a day and you do a funny thing where
you keep him on the phone right
well i've gotten to the point where they
hang up on me
i say who's this calling
do i know you and you did i call you
first
are you answering my call
what is your name what did you say your
name
and i go on like that till they hang up
that is really funny i think i got that
from you
well i'm glad i could give you something
oh honey you've given me so much uh wow
what what is it like to
when you have a grandson like justin
yeah that's a good question it's
wonderful especially when you go and buy
a little breakfast or lunch and the
clerks come up are you just in line
you like you should say to them who's he
yeah
i do sometimes
i do but i think that's rude i i i know
yeah
okay we're done you're looking at your
watch how do you feel how do i feel now
yeah
like it's over okay good all right it's
pretty much over uh but really quick uh
are you afraid of dying
you know that is a very
powerful question thank you
i think everybody's a little bit afraid
of dying i think everybody's a lot
afraid of dying
because you know what you've got here
you don't know what you've got there
right
and then i try to tell myself well i go
to sleep every night
if i didn't wake up in the morning
what would i know so then that scares me
that makes me think and there is no
hereafter oh then that's
don't i have any faith
i mean i could go crazy thinking about
this and then i say no i've got to have
faith
it's better to just
believe my beliefs that i've always
believed
just let god take care of it yeah
there has to be a god
it's hard to imagine that there's not
that god but some people a lot of people
don't believe in god but if nobody
believed in god this would not be a very
good world
so how do you want to make
the most of your time the remaining time
i keep asking god what he wants me to do
what does he say or she
you just gave me a look
you think god's a man for sure of course
does god have a gender i mean nobody's
ever seen god no but jesus christ was a
man
yes this man cisgender
i don't know i just if all the stuff
they've taught me all the stuff i've
learned all the stuff i believed in is
not true
what a horrible thing to play on people
i mean don't you have a sense of like
spirituality like beyond just what they
teach you in church like don't you ever
get a feeling like somebody's watching
over you or you see something in nature
that makes you
think there's something greater even if
it's not exactly what they tell you
about in the bible yeah you're right i
think about that
but but you're talking about the
hereafter like if there's not a
hereafter it bothered me when it was
okay for the catholics to to burn their
burn bodies yeah because to me is he's
going to raise you up and how do you
raise up
ashes that were thrown in the water but
maybe that was more symbolic he's going
to raise you up not necessarily like
directly from well he's talking about
the soul the soul yeah
did you ever question your faith before
you had gotten to be this age
yeah i
questioned it but then i always answer
it
that i feel safer believing yes
then not be yeah that makes sense did
you ever think about remarrying after
never oh really
my husband was dying he said to me now i
want you to feel free
and i want you to get married again
because you have a lot to offer
and i remember those words yeah
and i say oh
he won't find me getting married again
and he said why was life so terrible
no
no
but i don't want it to be and you never
know i was lucky you got lucky with a
nice guy he was a good guy great guy
was he afraid of not was he afraid or
was i think he would have married again
you think he would have that's funny he
was a very outgoing yeah and he was into
everything yeah he was a good dancer
oh god yes he was the only one i ever
danced with oh really
wow
wow okay you've now lived 11 decades
if you had to relive one of those
decades which would you relive oh
sorry to say
probably when i was first married maybe
the 40s the 40s yeah what life really
happened
yeah you were it was really that was
like
not the peak but that was when you were
oh i was really living that i was doing
everything and
it was a good time things were happening
what was the most drastic change looking
back over the decades
was it the computer age like when with
this or was it the 60s was it the like
sexual revolution vietnam and all that
or
for me the biggest thing was
the computer the technology that has
developed i'm totally amazed i say oh no
my mother and father my oh
my husband even came back yeah he'd say
what's going on oh my god they'd be so
confused right okay uh how do you want
people to remember you do you how do you
want it's a nice person
oh well i
i'll remember you that way
um
and do you have
a place picked out where you want to be
buried do you want to be
picked up it's all done right next to my
husband up north oh good
don't take it so you're saying you don't
want to move up north i was so afraid
and now you're going to end up
being up north for a long time yes i was
so afraid that on the tombstone it's got
my name born 1917.
died
and i said i think they got the 19 there
oh
so the last time i was up there we
looked and it didn't have that
okay okay so they can put the 20
whatever 21 maybe oh my god
it may be i mean people live to be 120s
um unbelievable do you ever use emojis
on the phone on the when you don't text
really do you no i don't no no no um
but you know what emojis are they're
just kind of like um
symbols they're like faces and different
i see them but i don't know how they get
there
if you could be a professional athlete
if you could have been an athlete what
would you have done
well i'm very jealous of the people that
swim well you know yeah
and i wish that i
were not afraid of the water i i had a
little teeny tiny tia it's a small
stroke once yeah in my pool oh i went
right down in the water oh boy
and there were two girls swimming they
came over and they said are you all
right and that ever felt funny yeah
and so they said come on we'll help you
out of the water so anyhow i knew i'd
had a little t.i.a
that's tmi
no t-i-a no i'm trans right
trans-ischemic
accidents oh well i remember you at a uh
what did i have at the cost yes
what was that that's when all my
medicines came out that was stuff came
well that was one of the scariest
moments because we were up at uh i did
surely i was dying so did i
i thought you were and i had to run i'd
live down a rural road and i had to run
out to the the closest kind of main road
and flag down there
flagged down the ambulance and i thought
that was i remember seeing you and
thinking oh
this is it i don't know what hit me at
that time they never discovered what
that was well i took all these tests
after that that's when the
four i have four prescriptions that's
when all the stuff started up old age i
guess for people who are listening who
want to know
maybe there's some sort of secret that
you don't even know is a secret it's
just how you live your life
what do you what do you eat what do you
avoid
well do you get stressed out just say
that i'm into the tv dinners oh you are
because i can't cook anymore like i used
to yeah so i used to i remember trying
to chop up this that and the other and
then i'd have to go lie down because my
back would be killing me
so then i would have to i think that's
what my back has been doing is shrinking
that's how i lost this height the
heights
i um
go out to eat several times a week
and bring stuff home all the time and
then i work around that there must be
something in your diet or something that
you've been doing
because your relatives didn't live that
long as you've been like gosh no wow the
oldest one was uncle joe and he was 71
when he died wow
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life you could only
have one
what is that
probably a cookie
which one
it doesn't matter your favorite cookie
you're going to the electric chair you
did something really bad i don't know
what and you're going to the electric
chair
i'm going to the electric chair yeah
it's your last meal and you can have
anything you want oh
yeah i have a gallon of ice cream
what flavor
coconut maybe i don't know coconut ice
cream
wow first of all they're going to be
amazing
coconut pineapple okay
okay weird
what's your favorite movie of all time
oh there were so many
see when cleopatra came out i was ah oh
really that was a big one you know when
um
yeah gone with the wind was good um
we're almost dead if we're almost dead
we're almost done that was not even a
joke
we're almost dead
um if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met who would they be
i would like to have met susan b anthony
oh i went by her house many times lou's
father lived down her street really like
when she was a kid you knew her well
after
her mother died then her father had to
go find a room someplace this is in
rochester yeah oh i didn't know she
lived in rochester oh yeah right off of
genesis street oh wow but anyhow um i
would like to have known her susan i
would like to have known ellen or
roosevelt oh yeah
you what would you have asked eleanor
roosevelt
how do you stand him
[Laughter]
people because he was a philander
because he was messing around on her
right yeah and she knew it yeah but um
weren't they related
i think they were second cousins or
something that's not good
all right that's good advice for the
listeners do not marry your second
cousins and uh who else kennedy john of
kennedy no his wife
oh yeah i thought she was quite a lady
she said well so you know all ladies
jackie you know that's powerful
wonderful women that'd be a cool dinner
i'd like to go i wouldn't want to have
to cook for them why because they their
tastes would be so
[Laughter]
um
if you could have one superpower what
would it be
stop all bad stuff uh-huh that's it
stop it
okay like
that would be have utopia what what i
wonder how what that would look like why
wouldn't it be good to have everything
good happening i agree okay if you had
to be one age for the rest of your life
physically what would it be
45 would be a good age oh yeah oh that's
good to know okay i got a few years left
to hit you're the optimal age stop at 45
okay
i'm always going to be 45. okay 45 until
i'm 103.
um or older if you could be reincarnated
as a non-human animal what animal would
you pick i think i'd like to be a dog
i'm going to ask you a very personal
question deeply personal
which do you prefer
wheel of fortune or jeopardy
i think jeopardy
like wheel of fortune's easy going yeah
you don't have to stress as much you
don't have to know everything yeah yeah
um okay orange juice if you had to drink
orange juice which you often do i drink
orange juice today pulp no pulp or lots
of pulp i mean i mean i'm having no pulp
these days but when i squeezed my own
there was plenty of pulp beetles the the
band the beetles or the rolling stones
well the beatles the rolling stones i
don't know too much but the beatles i
like a little bit you consider this pop
music modern music yeah yeah do you
remember when they burst on the scene do
you remember when when yeah i had kid in
high school yeah and did you what did
you think about the elvis and the
beatles did you think this is
filthy or no this is what the kids like
you know
but you weren't so much i i wasn't into
it i i didn't know one song from the
other who were you here i was busy in
the kitchen right
if you could leave me with one piece of
advice and the listeners what would your
advice to me be
well it's going to be very stupid of me
but
stay as sweet as you were oh
that's not stupid stay
justin okay
well i can do that all right well i love
you i love you too honey thanks for the
no i know
but i want the people to know
um thanks for doing this how much time
did you take of my time um well thanks
for phrasing it that way
[Music]
that happened i can't believe that
happened i know i'm so sorry it happened
it's so nice for us to have that yeah
you know we've been talking about doing
a version of this way before this
podcast started we were gonna do it on
film we were gonna for years we're gonna
record her on film and there's more i
there's more that i want to uh
get out of here yeah of course but um we
have a lot of videos we take a lot of
videos
and also you know what i really want to
do uh did we talk about this that i
would love to
contact sony we've been meaning to do
this for so long and try to get her
yeah it's getting harder it's getting
harder for her to get around like it's
her body is definitely failing her eyes
are failing her ears are feeling like
things are
well are like not working as well as i
used to but her brain as far as i can
see is distilled
i know it feels like it's just as sharp
as my brain yeah and it's a lot older
than my brain i saw it a week ago and it
was actually a weird compliment i gave
myself as smart no i know just as sharp
as me i know what you meant not that i'm
that sharp but no it was more about your
age right um it was so interesting to me
because it's my grandmother and i was
learning things about her that i never
knew so that alone was fascinating and
just the fact that we got her into this
little studio in florida and she sat
there for a couple hours and
and had the energy to do it i had like a
little thing of water i kept asking if
she wanted all of that was it was so
impressive to me um but i i couldn't
help but wonder
if it would be at all interesting to
anybody else who didn't know her because
you know she's not a celebrity and that
in the show we have accomplished uh
known people on right uh so i don't know
i i still don't know if it if it is
going to translate
it may not for many people i think it
might though to hear from a you know she
was talking about
the things that
i she saw way back in the day and the
the the four line uh four party time
phones
iceman cometh it was funny funny joke oh
yeah well some things that i didn't know
she made up nell oh yeah i didn't as a
middle name i didn't know that
she had a brother who died at six months
her i didn't know that her father had
read curly hair
uh i didn't know how she met grandpa
i didn't know that her mother was
basically raised by rich people i didn't
either i didn't know that her favorite
ice cream was coconut pineapple i mean
that's a lesson again i think everyone
should while their
elderly relatives are still with us they
should take the time to chronicle not
necessarily interview them in a formal
way but ask them yeah these questions
ask about their lives learn more about
them while you can and they'd probably
really appreciate it i'm sure um i'm
just going to read you things that uh
that she was born before she was born
before electric refrigerators
she was born before the pop-up toaster
she was born before nathan handwecker
sold the first nathan's hot dog at coney
island
before we entered world war one before
woodrow wilson sent troops into mexico
to pursue pancho villa before daylight
savings time went into effect
so that's why the world to see the world
through her lens must be and it's
amazing she doesn't text fine but she
emails
she has a kindle she can do skype she
knows how to rent
library books onto her kindle yeah and
she knows how to email it's really funny
she's so few things on her wall she's
it's all pictures of like family but
very prominently displayed as a a cutout
of the newspaper from an advertisement
for going the distance this movie i did
with drew barrymore and um it's all like
yellowed now it's it's not even like in
frame it's just like it's like tasty
it's really sweet
uh and yeah
um
she was very excited to meet drew i
remember when she she met of course
because also
i mean drew was from
to barrymore so that's true so my
grandma was a fan of her grandpa
yeah she was a fan of her grand uncles
in fact john barrymore was the reason
the term matinee idol exists
women would um
when their husbands this is back in the
day so
that when they would go to work women
would stay home and they would go to the
movies during the day they would go see
matinees and
and they'd see the handsome actors and
then john barrymore was the first one to
whom the the term
matinee idol was coined for whom
she was talking about her father coming
over and getting seasick
on the way from italy and
and that was the main reason he didn't
want to go back and go back home because
he was like i'm not going back and then
how long was it again it was like 10
minutes it was a long time which not i
don't blame him seasick that i'm sure i
would too but
it made me realize and think about
something that i think about often how
unlikely it is for us to be alive well
for us to be us for us
neil degrasse i was thinking about it
with him but
but just think if
our
oh my god had a stronger stomach let's
say and didn't get seasick and had gone
back to italy we wouldn't be talking
right now i mean it's something that
simple and then
again she i was reminded of it when she
was talking about her husband having the
problem with his ear and failing the
medical exam and not being able to go to
world war ii
that very well could have couldn't have
caught that couldn't cause that problem
grandpa would have not but all these
little things along the way that it's a
miracle and then you think article that
we're alive and
and thinking that way and reminding
myself of that miracle always makes me
feel so much better and and less scared
of of um like neil degrasse tyson i'm
saying less scared of not being alive
because it's so unlikely that we know
are and so just to enjoy and again yet
another reason another highlight uh
another way to amplify like how
important it is that's why i love about
these letters like people are like i
just want to enjoy
this time i want to do what i can and if
that means like getting mentally well
and going to therapy if that means like
taking up [ __ ] fly fishing and
finding happiness is god so yeah vital
um also interesting uh
that i thought you were gonna say how
the chance that we'd be like italian
we'd be like a italian like
rural farmer but we wouldn't be italian
countrymen we wouldn't be able to us
yeah we wouldn't be i mean
we wouldn't be we wouldn't be
it's just i mean it's that simple like
it everything has to
happen in a very specific way well
that's why i wonder if again to get back
to your first point like is this is this
more interesting like selfishly for us
because this is about our
genesis i mean this is about i'm sure
i'm sure i mean and specifically i mean
it is definitely more interesting but
like is it at all interesting if you're
not i don't know well we'll see
i mean it's interesting to me just like
something like
um
she was talking about her mother dying
at a young age and her father
having these three girls to raise all by
himself and he became very very strict
and wouldn't let and became very
protective and wouldn't let my god our
grandmother you know do anything danger
remotely dangerous and as a result we
see direct results yeah our grandmother
uh had our mother and she instilled that
a certain level of fear and neurosis in
our mother and now in a causal way has
has
resulted in us being scared of uh ice
skating yeah it's why it's this is such
an interesting topic that is why empathy
is so important and like this is sort of
like a quirky neurotic thing that we
have but
a deeper more tragic trauma can be
passed on too that's
they've documented that from you know
the holocaust we know people
our generation whom it's still affecting
this tragedy of a people and a trauma of
a family gets will get past passed down
and now i wonder if like where
the fact that we value the sense of
humor or or
where somebody's proclivities like you
come from like personalities come from
it's so hard to know it's fun to know
she's funny yeah she's funny the the way
she handles uh telemarketers is she she
says she gets it from you but i don't
think so i think
that's really clever where she acts
senile 102 year old woman acting senile
to outsmart a telemarketer is one of the
best things i've ever heard
it's really hard to beat that yeah it
was really sad
to hear her talk about uh losing her mom
and i realized why i was especially sad
because
for my entire life
grandma has been an old person so i
always saw her as someone who was had
things figured out and it was settled
emotionally with all her issues and so
to hear her vulnerable and
and to hear her talking about a time in
her life where she was young and trying
to figure things out and
and so hurt by this thing that happened
was
really hard to hear i thought it was
really hard for me to hear and kind of
jarring in a way because i had never
seen
that uh vulnerability from her in my
life i don't think that's true and it
completely explained any of her
um
formerly annoying characteristics like
you know being overly concerned and
neuroses uh
it made me
see her
maybe see her much more clearly than i
ever have yeah
there's so many things that made me
laugh and i don't know if people are
gonna
like
uh identify with but she's afraid of
getting in trouble with the law because
her father fudged her birth certificate
by a day like yeah she didn't have the
idea that
uh i love that you you kind of tricked
her into no cannot imagine into you she
was like oh we're not recording yet i
don't know we're not recording and she's
like i gotta say this again
you know she backfired that was funny i
was trying to like
i know what you're trying to do trying
to make her comfortable yeah
yeah i'm talking about her girlfriend
lou
and her platonic girlfriend luke
her about emojis yeah i see them but i
don't know how they get there
there's some there's some lines that
made me laugh so hard
oh how about uh mom getting
propositioned by your uncle
oh yeah that was news
and things i never thought i'd hear from
500 please alex
i was so curious to know more about that
but i don't want to know more about that
but that's crazy i kind of want to know
what the proposition was i know i hope
it was just like do you want to go see a
movie and she misread it yeah maybe back
then the term proposition meant
something different than it means now
it was before
proposal yeah
it was like when gay applied to a town
fair
her talking about dying and uh she said
you know she said in such a simple way
and it made me realize
she's been wrestling with the idea of
life and death and religion all these
things for over 100 years and
what she has the way she thinks about it
is she said you know you know you got
here you know that you don't know what
you've got there right and i feel safer
believing than not believing it's she
makes it yeah very simple and i think
the lesson i got from that was
no matter how you deal with your faith
and and your fear of death and
all of that it kind of always comes back
to something very simple which is
we know we have here
we don't know what we have there
and i'm going to choose to believe a
certain thing
because it makes me feel good to think
that well the unknown is scary yeah i
mean it's as simple as that and that's
why this is the
great unknown but there's something kind
of beautiful in the simplicity of i know
of acknowledging that truth of we don't
know
and i'm just going to choose to have
faith because i've had faith my whole
life i don't want to change now and it's
comforting and especially when you're
someone
who you really want to comfort um
expresses any sort of fears and
you know i've wrestled with
uh my religious beliefs and spirituality
and
but i would never want to
lead her away from believing in
something like that i i
right but also she doesn't she's not on
any high horse no like a lot of i know
people are who are
very religious and i consider her very
religious yeah and she doesn't look down
on people who aren't i mean that you you
didn't hear that in this interview but i
know this to be true that she is
um she sees her religion as a very
personal thing that she it makes her
feel good it's what she knows um but
she's not judgmental about other people
i've i've never noticed and yet she has
this like issue with elliot not being
baptized during the right amount of time
yeah but that's just that but that's
just her family tradition i mean
old people like
to keep traditions alive and
understandably i think you know the
older you get the more
it makes sense to want to
um hold on to what you know yeah
especially now with the world changing
so rapidly i can only imagine and she's
done like we said she's done a
remarkable job of keeping up with all
these changes that have that have
occurred and obviously like any old
person she's
you know she has some more old-fashioned
thoughts and and she struggles with
certain things that are happening but i
would say for the most part she's pretty
pretty pretty damn woke yeah she's gonna
damn hip for uh she is almost 103 year
old she's a woke 103 year old it struck
me when uh you asked what three people
she would want to have dinner with
and she
lit up and she was like oh
she did that like she was giddy at the
idea of this fantasy of having a dinner
with susan b anthony and eleanor
roosevelt um by the way maybe that's the
afterlife maybe i hope so for her case
but it made sense to me that she would
get so excited by the thought of
something like that because i think
that's the number one thing if i had to
say like what's your secret what's
keeping your life it's that it's yeah
it's the curiosity it's the
zeal for for life and just the prospect
of this fun fancy dinner with these
legendary women it like kind of webbs
yeah you know it woke something into it
it did
yeah she is she's goals she's girls
she's goals she's life goals and you
know we should also have our father's
mother on here yeah because she'd be
fascinating to talk to too because right
now we we want to reach out to the uh
people at guinness and oh that's right
we want to find out who the oldest
podcast guest
uh ever i was and i i would be
surprised if there was someone older and
if there was someone older than grandma
i don't think they uh are jeopardy
masters like her she also does crossword
puzzles every day she's incredible
across her puzzles i will say this i bet
she is the wokest funniest centurion to
ever be on a podcast i think that's safe
to say but i i don't know how you
measure that so it's probably not in
guinness but uh we should we i'm so
curious i have a feeling she might be i
mean maybe there was one guest who was
like i'm uh
exactly exactly um
but enough about bragging about it okay
yeah yeah but she's the best and uh
we love her i'm so happy that that
happened yeah
let's read a lot i wonder if she's
listening i hope so well we love you
grandma uh let's read a letter okay
this is from ellen
d
subject making the most of it green
heart hi justin and christian your
podcast is so fantastic and just what i
need every week the past couple of years
have been very challenging for me when i
was 35 i decided to go back to school
for what turned out to be a very
intensive music therapy program
i'm nearing the end of my 100 1040 hours
of internship for this program and will
be eligible to sit for my board exams by
christmas which is very exciting for me
congratulations uh what an
accomplishment um i live in south dakota
cool so the opportunities for clinical
experience and music therapy outside of
my hospital are very limited because of
this the closest internship in mental
health my passion is four hours away in
minneapolis uh that's where your podcast
comes in i listen on my drive up oh she
goes there every week and it helps me
get out of my own head a little bit
listening to you and your guests talk
about the work that you've done together
the work they've done that has intrigued
you etc has really reminded me of how
much the arts matter to people what we
do with our art has the potential to
change a person's life to the point that
they might stick around this world long
enough to inspire a whole new round of
people searching for meaning and purpose
that's such a great way to put it in
turn this reminder has inspired me to
start performing again cool
something i was hesitant to do as i
didn't want to take the focus from my
work and put it on my ego
music for me is more than quote everyone
come listen to how great i am it's an
aesthetic experience that i want to
share with those who are open to receive
it but it's also something that makes me
feel more alive than anything else so
thanks for that reminder having this
podcast sharing your joys in your work
and just for being you and being so
honest with your guests and listeners
i'm about to cry you are yeah you're
cheering up that is so
nice and and what you're doing is
inspiring too
ellen d
from sioux falls south dakota that's
very cool so cool god that is really
nice to hear uh grandma is like that
with
jeopardy i mean it's it sounds
maybe silly but uh
wherever you can find that in life is
a gift and um i can't believe you're
driving four hours too so i'm glad we
could keep you company and thank you for
sharing that um and if anyone would like
to share anything else similar to that
uh or very difficult yeah why does it
have to be similar that's a that's a
tall order that's very nice uh we love
hearing from you guys and i know we only
read one of these a week
uh but we get them all we're getting
them all and we're reading them all and
uh they're they're really i know we want
to read a bunch but yeah there's so many
that are definitely worth sharing um so
anyway uh please continue to write in
life is short at wondery.com
this has been life for sure yes with our
oldest guest and uh on this thanksgiving
week
we uh we thought it would be appropriate
to have her as a guest um and i hope
everyone enjoyed listening to this and i
hope everyone enjoys spending time with
their
loved ones and their grandparents and um
young and young and old and i hope
everyone has a really
wonderful holiday and thanks for
spending time with us yeah that was nice
thank you for indulging us because we
definitely got a lot from that
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long jody lesniak's son grandson
freudian
and
our producer is jody's other grandson
and life is short is also produced by
megan monaco our senior producer is
michelle miche lans audio engineers
marcelino via pondo
executive producers are marshall louie
and hernan lopez ford wondering
[Music]
okay
oops
it's a foot of the chair
okay i would make a terrible blind
person
unfortunately you don't have to worry
about that well i don't know yeah well
now you don't be positive
let me get comfortable okay
why don't you take the keys off your
wrist
[Music]
like you want me to stand up no no i
think it's uh
there's got to be a way to lower this
way
there is a way to lower it yeah you know
what can you stand yeah why don't you
stand up chris okay
wait okay
okay
oh okay i see
did i sit in the wrong chair
oh sorry you need to raise it a little
lower okay let me help you
pardon me one second and i'll do it for
her oh i'm sorry i'm gonna go all the
way down
oh great oh great thank you that's it
yeah
well he's an expert
so you're ready
oh great
all right
and i have to eat it
yeah you have to eat the microphone
but grandma remember just talk to to
yeah i can
let us know if we're off mike or uh i
wish okay cool
do i have to speak up
uh do you want to sit in here no no no
no i'll be out here are you sure yeah
all right
okay
how do you feel
silly
[Music]
i feel so stupid oh wait wait let's get
you some water in case you want water
that's a very good idea yeah
do you guys have any water
when did i say yes to
[Music]
this are you regretting it
i i feel so
um
not me oh really well try to feel like
you
[Music]
you